the following trailer is written as for
spoilers
[Music]
from the studio who finally buckled and
released the snyder card but are holding
firm with david ayer fans no we are not
going down this road again i don't care
what happened on a submarine wait what
happened on a submarine comes the film
that only exists because james gunn made
one too many pedo tweets for disney and
dc swooped in like come on home gunny
boy let the jizz jokes fly it's like
angels are splooting all low for us
the suicide squad
what is this movie
some kind of
suicide squad
yes but also no get ready for the same
basic premise but a massively different
direction
replacing figurative jokes with actual
jokes endless character introductions
with no character introductions and
changing the title from suicide squad to
the suicide squad see there's a little
duh on the poster so everyone knows it's
a new movie with a bunch of the same
characters oh boy no wonder this bombed
welcome back actors eager to watch the
stank off their last outing as these
characters like viola davis bringing way
too much talent and pedigree to a film
with pete davidson in it okay joel
kinnaman who somehow makes you care
about rick flagg to the point where his
death hits the hardest i blame you
katana you're supposed to have his back
and of course margot robbie in her third
appearance as harley quinn and third
wildly different version of the
character going from stripper scipies to
self-actualized badass to a twee
romantic with a head full of flowers and
birds who still manages to steal the
film in a sequence full of torture dead
goons and close-up foot stuff or as
tarantino calls it
i'm in a humming hominer
but forget the og squad not that they
ever can there's a whole new side squad
in town featuring idris elba as will
smith said no to the sequel i mean
bloodsport this other sharpshooter on a
mission to save his daughter will have
audiences everywhere wondering if
there's a draft of the script that still
has deadshot's name on it john cena's
peacemaker the kind of guy dwight
schrute imagines himself to be he does
exactly what i do but better i am better
than you have ever been or ever will be
then there's polka dot man a guy cursed
with exploding polka dots on the outside
and the mental state of your typical
incel on the inside ratcatcher 2 who
gets dismissed as a lazy millennial
millennial but i'm pretty sure she just
has mono we're tired colonel we need a
rest
[Music]
a disgusting weasel you wouldn't let
near your children know the other one
some glorified cameos to give james
gunn's buddies a nice payday and the
cutest actually threatening animal
sidekick since the last three cute but
actually threatening animal sidekicks
please please please give us behind the
scenes of stallone's video sessions for
this i need it new dumb friends
follow the smartly crew of outcasts as
they do an adorkable version of the bay
of pigs featuring an extended massacre
of freedom fighters play for laughs
then innocent man had his wiener out
cause when the usa has to do a good
old-fashioned south american coup amanda
waller won't hesitate to build a team
with one crucial thing in common
traumatic parent stuff my father's
burdens
we too heavy to carry my old man one day
he just
locked me in a crate for 24 hours and it
was full of starving rats his father was
a soldier who trained his son how to
kill from the moment he was born my
mother was a scientist at star labs and
she was obsessed with turning me and my
brothers and sisters into superheroes
she infected me
and we don't really know what's up with
harley quinn's dad but come on it's
nothing good right i think you have a
serious case of daddy issues you all do
even the guardians all do james gunn
hates dads when thanos took my home
world he killed my parents in front of
me every time my sister prevailed
my father would replace a piece of me
with machinery just like my own damn
parents who sold me no little baby into
slavery
that's my freaking father and apparently
birds too
so strap in for a chaotic good time with
a little bit of everything hilarious
violence
[Music]
dicks a gen xer's greatest hits mixtape
chapter headings that make you say ooh
disgusting animals that make you say oh
and a finale where rats eat a giant
eyeball that doesn't make you say
come on people see this movie why
couldn't they just call it suicide squad
we're sorry and we promise we did better
this time
starring
well well well if it isn't rickman the
guy who can flag anything
i'm going to become the poker
will smith
why are you showing a blank screen
there's nothing oh i get it rocky shark
doo doo doo doo doo come on everybody
cover me bad
the dick of it astaro is born
saturday narc dies
i'm mary pop
and the air cut who are you going to
show that to god damn people deserve no
i'm gonna need that drive colonel no one
is saying what they did was right that
information gets out it causes an
international incident
suicide squad we're sorry and we promise
we did better this time
it takes everyone way too long to figure
out the anti-star strategy is just cover
your face feels like that would be kind
of your first reflex if a big starfish
was flying straight at it right no
harley quinn versus the joker who are
you picking in a fight whose crimes do
you think have caused more economic
damage what kind of body counts have
they racked up we're tracking all their
crucial on-screen stats in the latest
episode of buy the numbers click the box
on the right to see who wins
this is james gunn he's got my back i
would advise not firing him his movie
stern hated characters beloved
nom nom
don't believe in yourself believe in the
me that believes in you blah blah blah
blah
thanks for watching